باي طريقه تفضل ان تموت سؤال ربما يخشاه
المحكومون بالاعدام في الولايات المتحده
اكثر مما يخشون الموت نفسه ما بين الكرسي
الكهربائي والرمي بالرصاص وسائل مختلفه
لتنفيذ الحكم لكن احداها تثير جدلا كبيرا
منذ اعتمادها كاحدى طرق الموت انها الحقنه
القاتله
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده منه
عالم غريب
لا تقوم باعدام بالحقنه القاتله اريد ان
تنتهي حياتي بساقه على الكرسي الكهربائي
كانت هذه الكلمات اخر ما تفوه به السجين
الامريكي ادمونكي قبل ان يوثق جسده بكرسي
كهربائي تمهيدا للحظه اعدامه لكن لماذا
يخشى المحكوم عليهم بالاعدام على الحقنه
القاتله
الحقنه القاتله واحده من اكثر الاساليب
شيوعا لتنفيذ احكام الاعدام في امريكا
ويتم الحقن القاتل بعده طرق اشهرها مسجد
ثلاثه محاليل كيميائيه
للصوديوم الذي يعمل على تغييب المتهم عن
الوعي وكلوريد البوتاسيوم الذي يؤدي الى
توقف القلب وراكي رانيا لايقاف عمليه
التنفس لدى المحكوم عليهم بالاعدام
عرفت حقنه الاعدام للمره الاولى عام
1888 عندما اقترح طبيب من نيويورك يدعى
يوليوس بلير تطبيقها بحجه ان الاجراءات
اللازمه لها ارخص من اجراءات الاعدام شنقا
اسلوب الاعدام بالحقنه المميته استخدم
لاحقا في الصين وغواتيمالا والفلبين
وتايلاند وغيرها كما استخدم ايضا في حالات
القتل الرحيم لتسهيل الموت الطوعي للمرضى
الراغبين في انهاء حياتهم العديد من
الانتقادات وجهت لحقنه الاعدام ووصفت
بانها عقوبه قاسيه وتسبب الكثير من الالم
وكانت سببا رئيسيا في تعليق عقوبات
الاعدام لمده سته اشهر في ولايه اوكلاهوما
بعد معاناه رهيبه استمرت لاربعين دقيقه
للمحكوم عليه بالاعدام
بينما كان المسؤولون عن اعدامه يجربون
طريقه جديده
للحقنه القاتله
[موسيقى]
من يضمان
في عام 2011 حضر الاتحاد الاوروبي الادويه
المستخدمه في تحضير الحقن القاتله لذلك
اضطرت بعض الدول والولايات الامريكيه
للبحث عن محاليل بديله لتحضير حقن الاعدام
يعني
في اروقه الموت خلف ابواب السجون هناك
منقضت العداله بان يكون مصيرهم الموت جزاء
لما اقترفته ايديهم يعلمون جيدا ان لحظه
الاعدام قادمه لا محاله وربما جل ما
يتمناونه هو موت بلا الم لكن يبدو انه
مهما تعددت اشكاله تبقى للموت الام لا
يعلمها الا من فارق الدنيا